looking back on it now what were the
drawbacks and the benefits to making so
many shorts and do you think it was
worth it I know you wanted to make a
feature much sooner yeah I would say
that for me personally it's worked out
just fine I've taken an unusual path
I've taken a very patient path I wanted
to prepare myself as much as possible
about my short films as I'd mentioned
before and I'd and I did that so I
didn't want to get into the director's
chair for a feature and below it it's
hard enough to get that first chance I
didn't want to get there and blow it and
never get another chance so for me it
worked out nicely but it took 15 years
15 odd years whatever was 10 years
whereas other people go listen I'm gonna
go for it from the beginning and again
some of them make it early and since
they're younger than me I mean you know
agencies love hot up-and-coming talent
so if you're young mid-20s and you make
something really cool you're gonna get
more attention than if I make something
cool it's just kind of the way the
business at least the industry on here
is just kind of set up so I can't say
the way I did it is right or wrong or or
whatnot you know I've always been a
patient guy I've always taken my own
road to things so you know I think it's
been beneficial to me obviously the
drawbacks are I'm 40 and I only have
what will soon be two features under my
belt and if I take in a slightly
different path maybe I don't have ten at
this point you know but that's a
drawback I'm willing to live with I
think I did it the only way that it was
ever gonna work for me you know and it's
an interesting question because if you
ask 10 other filmmakers what they think
of my strategy they might laugh their
heads off for all I know I don't know
but it's just it's a weird business
everyone's on their own you were totally
on you can read as many books on the
subject as you want
the reality is is no one's going to give
you anything you've got to go out there
and earn it through talent and hard work
perseverance and all those kind of
things in every single filmmaker myself
included
every single filmmaker ever
literally has their own fascinating
story as to how they got it done how
they got noticed and some of them might
be more successful in others in terms of
how far they've risen and what level of
movies they're doing now but all of them
just literally found their way through
the labyrinthian maze that is Hollywood
and made it wherever they are these days
can you recommend any resources for a
young filmmaker starting out I know you
said everybody has their own paths are
there some resources that have been
really valuable for you in terms of DIY
sort of not just not learning about film
theory or whatever no sure sure no I
understand I listen I I'm sure there's a
million books on the subject and I read
many in college that were perfectly fine
literally in terms of people from a
nuts-and-bolts standpoint you know what
do I do
how do i how do i start directing at all
or whatever i would recommend just
getting on set get on as a PA get on
whatever you can get on a lot of sense
figure out how a set works you don't
have to become an expert at it you don't
have to spend five years on the set but
get on the set figure it out figured out
the world that you're gonna be living in
and leading at some point as certainly
as director know that world and that is
the very seedling to you starting to put
together your own world I would
recommend working at places that will
teach you what you need to know if
you're not on set go work at a camera
rental house learn the gear if you want
to get into writing and producing work
at an agency work at a management
company work at a production company you
know I would learn who's in your
business who do you want to know there's
a lot of assistance out there figure out
who works for who network in terms of
gear become an expert at it you don't
have to become you know someone who's
paid a thousand dollars a day to run the
gear but no one from a general
standpoint know what you need know what
you don't need
if you're writing I would say one of the
best steps you can do is is read great
screenplays they're all online these
days anyhow read The Godfather read
you can read new scripts old scripts
read read read read and then read some
more figure out what made them great
then start writing yourself and write
and write and write probably gonna be
pretty awful at first it'll get better
until you start to find your own voice
and you know that's what you do whether
you're learning the gear and pulling it
together to start tackling producing and
directing your own short film or whether
you're writing your own scripts don't be
intimidated by it don't be scared by it
you just do it and then you do it again
and then you do it again and again and
again and keep honing it until you learn
what you need to and I think both will
learn along the way more so than most
books can tell you learn through
experience you say that horror sparks
conversation I think a great story
sparks conversation I think horror can
spark certain visceral reactions yeah I
I I think a great film my dream as a
filmmaker is have one of my scripts or
one of my films cause an audience
audience to leave the theater and go and
talk about it and debate about it and
think about it I don't necessarily want
to make the type of movie that they eat
their popcorn they walk away and by the
time they get to the car they don't
remember what they just saw some fun
movie or whatever I think any great
story or included is something that will
make people talk and and I mentioned
privilege before I I do think it's a
privilege to be in a position where I
can build stories and characters and
tell stories that I think aim to make
you see the world and your place in it
for maybe a different perspective I
think that's a very powerful thing that
we do and have the ability to do and I
aspire to do it even better than I then
I do so now but yeah and short I think
any great film should spark discussion I
think that's the goal I think you should
be something that inspires you or
traumatizes you were scares you know
whatever reaction is the point of your
story I think that should always be the
point to get a reaction otherwise your
films just putting people to sleep you
know so at least that so that's that's
what that's what I aim for
you